in this video we'll study the encoder
architecture
an example of a popular encoder only
architecture is bert which is the most
popular model of its kind
let's first start by understanding how
it works
we'll use a small example using three
words we use these as inputs and pass
them through the encoder
we retrieve a numerical representation
of each word
for example the encoder converts those
three words welcome to nyc
in these three sequences of numbers the
encoder outputs exactly one sequence of
numbers
per input word this numerical
representation
can also be called a feature vector or a
feature tensor
let's dive in this representation it
contains one vector per word that was
passed through the encoder
each of this vector is a numerical
representation of the word in question
the dimension of that vector is defined
by the architecture of the model
for the base bert model it is 768.
these representations contain the value
of a word but contextualized
for example the vector attributed to the
word to
isn't the representation of only the two
word
it also takes into account the words
around it
which we call the context as in it looks
to the
left context the words on the left of
the one we're studying
here the word welcome and the context on
the right
here the word nyc and it outputs a value
for the word
given its context it is therefore a
contextualized value
one could say that the vector of 768
values
holds the meaning of the word within the
text
it does this thanks to the
self-attention mechanism
the self-retention mechanism relates to
different positions
or different words in a single sequence
in order to compute a representation
of that sequence as we've seen before
this means that the resulting
representation of a word has been
affected by
other words in the sequence
we won't dive into these specifics here
but we'll offer some further readings if
you want to get a better understanding
at what happens
under the hood so when should one use an
encoder
encoders can be used as standalone
models in a wide variety of tasks
for example bert arguably the most
famous transformer model
is a standalone encoder model and at the
time of release it beat the state of the
art
in many sequence classification tasks
question answering tasks
and masked language modeling to only
cite a few
the idea is that encoders are very
powerful at extracting
vectors that carry meaningful
information about a sequence
this vector can then be handled down the
road by additional neurons to make sense
of them
let's take a look at some examples where
encoders really shine
first of all masked language modelling
or mlm
it's the task of predicting a hidden
word in a sequence of words
here for example we have hidden the word
between my and is
this is one of the objectives with which
bert was trained it was trained to
predict
hidden words in a sequence encoders
shine in this scenario in particular
as bi-directional information is crucial
here
if we didn't have the words on the right
is silva and the dot
then there is very little chance that
bert would have been able to identify
name
as the correct word the encoder needs to
have a good understanding of the
sequence in order to predict a masked
word
as even if the text is grammatically
correct
it does not necessarily make sense in
the context of the sequence
as mentioned earlier encoders are good
at doing sequence classification
sentiment analysis is an example of
sequence classification
the model's aim is to identify the
sentiment of a sequence
it can range from giving a sequence a
rating from one to five stars if doing
review analysis
to giving a positive or negative rating
to a sequence
which is what is shown here for example
here given the two sequences
we use the model to compute a prediction
and to classify the sequences among
these two classes
positive and negative while the two
sequences are very similar
containing the same words the meaning is
entirely different
and the encoder model is able to grasp
that difference
you